good morning and welcome to the NCBI
minute an updated PubMed is on its way
today I'm here with Kathy Kay nice and
Jessica chan from the PubMed team my
name is Marie Collins and I'll be doing
the talking but Jessica will be doing
the typing in the questions pod if we
don't get to your questions we've got a
lot of people on the line if we don't
get to questions you can always reach
out to us and send feedback after the
webinar today
I want to talk about the new PubMed I'm
going to start with the roadmap or
timeline because that seems to be the
number one question that we get from
folks I'll talk about the goals the
agile development model sort of why we
built PubMed and a new PubMed and how
we've built a new PubMed I'll talk about
the features that have already been
released in PubMed Labs the features
that are still to come the responsive
design of the new PubMed and then I have
a couple of slides about communication
and planning for the transition to the
new PubMed I'm starting with the mission
statement or just overarching goal for
the new PubMed we're transforming PubMed
into a modern hub with a fast reliable
and intuitive search that connects
people to the world's leading sources of
biomedical information and when you read
this statement I think every time I read
the statement I think this new PubMed
really is in line with the goals of NIH
the goals of the NLM strategic plan for
sure and it sort of been captures the
world that we all work in every day here
at NCBI this is pretty much what we do
the roadmap if you are not familiar with
the new PubMed this will be completely
new to you if you have seen a previous
presentation or read a previous TD
article about the new PubMed this will
be a shift for you the plan as it stands
right now which i think is a pretty
solid plan is to have PubMed Labs which
is running right now you can see in the
yellow on that top or PubMed Labs is is
up and running but it is not the current
production PubMed January of 2020 we
and to make PubMed Labs the default
production PubMed so arriving at PubMed
early next year you'll arrive at the new
PubMed current production PubMed at that
time will remain archived and available
for several months I'll talk briefly
about the goals for the new PubMed again
people who've seen other presentations
this might be a little repetitive but I
also am hoping to reach people who just
weren't aware at all that we were going
to a new PubMed we're shifting PubMed to
a modern cloud architecture focusing on
a high quality search the new PubMed
will be fast and reliable at least as
fast and reliable as current production
PubMed it will deliver a modern
experience and our overarching goal for
this development is that we build a
system that is beloved people love
current PubMed we really hope they're
going to love new PubMed when it
launches we've built this in an agile
development environment this means that
we've released a Minimum Viable Product
with enough features for early users and
at the same time we established an
environment to capture feedback for
future development we've released new
features frequently and we pay
continuous attention to technical
excellence and good design so who did we
talk to in building this new PubMed we
talked to clinicians researchers
professors librarians journalists grant
writers buyer curators health advocates
and PubMed team members our research our
usability testing our interviews have
been exhaustive and they have been
ongoing in an agile environment you can
continue to do this usability testing
throughout the lifecycle of the project
just two weeks ago we had some usability
experts at the clinical Center at NIH
showing folks the PubMed labs on the
mobile device and testing the usability
they are getting feedback that will
further inform our development so this
is a huge endeavor it's a huge project
it's a huge shift from the current
production PubMed moving it to the cloud
it's not just an interface refresh
however what our users will see is the
interface refresh so I'm starting here
and the bulk of my presentation will
actually be on the features of this new
PubMed I'm going to start with what
you'll see in this new interface when
you're in pubmed labs if you're looking
at a single citation and then I'll sort
of go back to you you've run a search
and you've gotten your results and all
the things you can do with a full result
set so I've got the URL here if you'd
like to open a web web browser and play
along you can look at labs either for
the first time or again if you've been
there before I'm going to start if you
were to run a search in pubmed labs and
look at a single citation I'll show you
some of the things that you'll see there
so here I'm looking at an abstract in
PubMed Labs you can see that we've added
this navigation from within a single
result so you can go from one result to
the next without going back to your full
results list and if you hover over that
previous or next button you'll see a
little bit of details for the citation
that either comes before or after this
one also when you're looking at a single
abstract you'll see that we have the
full-text links you have publisher links
the PMC link if the articles available
in PMC and now we've added the library
link out using outside tool and you can
see up to five library icons if you're
affiliated with a hospital as well as a
university for example you can display
the icons for all of the institutions
you're affiliated with and take
advantage of all of those subscriptions
we have a new site button that I'll show
you a little bit later we've added the
favorites button you can share to
Twitter Facebook or grab a permalink and
we have page navigation you can use the
navigation menu to jump right down to
similar articles or references or the
linked out resources or you can just
scroll through this abstract page to see
the rest of the information that's below
the abstract now back to our results
page there's a lot going on here I'm
hoping today what you'll see of PubMed
Labs will assure you that it is feature
and we'll go through this each of these
features and well most of these features
in a little bit more detail so we have
the results by year graph you can click
on the arrows to expand it you can use
the little circles there on the bottom
to narrow or broaden your year range we
have the same email and more Actions
menu we have a best match sort order by
default but you can easily toggle to
most recent you can change your view
from the summary view that you see in
front of you on this screen to the full
abstract view you can see here that we
have added these snippets with
highlights so that you can scroll
through your results and see why this
result was returned get a little bit
more information before you go into the
full abstract we have filters very
recently we've added the ability to
customize this filters menu and I'll
talk about that in a minute you can
create an alert you can go to advanced
search and under each item as well as
when you're looking at a single abstract
you can use that cite feature or share
the article I'm gonna start with the
cite feature because it's very exciting
and new and something we've never had in
PubMed before you can grab the citation
for an abstract with that cite button
the text is already highlighted you can
hit control C you can click on the copy
button you can download that citation in
an RIS file and the formats available
are AMA MLA APA and the NLM format you
can share by clicking on that link again
it's the Twitter Facebook or grabbing
the permalink you can save and email
your results as you do today I've
selected two citations I can click on
either save or email the options for
saving to file would be to save all the
results on the page all the results of
your search or the selected items and
the format's available there are summary
ris pmid list or abstract the email
options you can email all the results on
the page or selected I
in either the summary or abstract either
text or not just the text format with
the rich text there's a more Actions
menu and this is where you'll find those
send to features you can send your items
either to the clipboard or to a
collection the clipboard allows you to I
add up to 500 citations to a temporary
clipboard and it pops up I think the
messages in PubMed Labs the way that
they appear on the screen you don't tend
to overlook them as much as you might in
production PubMed so I sort of like this
when you add the two items to the
clipboard
you see a message there and also where
the red arrow is you'll see now that
clipboard link appears also with your
advanced search and create alert so it's
really easy to remember that you have a
clipboard and to navigate to your
clipboard and see what you've been
collecting their collections you can add
up to a thousand citations in a
collection in your my NCBI account and I
personally prefer collections because
they're persistent and this will be my
first plug for if you don't already have
one register for a my NCBI account
filters as I said we have default
filters on the left sidebar menu
I think the filters are a little bit
more intuitive in PubMed labs where you
can tell whether they're selected or not
selected because they have that empty
check box right now I don't have any
filters selected I can add more filters
to this menu by clicking on the
additional filters met button a pop-up
will appear and I can select from the
various categories that you see here so
in this case I've gone to the age
category selected two more filters and
when I click on apply those filters will
now appear in my filters menu and I can
check them to select them or deselect
them as I as I need to when I'm
searching speaking of filters and
speaking of being agile my NCBI custom
filters were rolled into production
pubmed labs yesterday so this slide I
added to the slide deck yesterday as
well so now if you're logged into your
my NCBI account
and you've set up custom filters you'll
see them appear there above the results
by year graph we sort of felt that if
you if you have these filters you want
to be able to access them so there they
are for you advanced searching and
history is available this is a feature
that not used by everyone but loved by
the folks who do use it it allows you to
search specific fields you can show in
index if you have a search term in here
and you want to click on show index
it'll let you see all of the results you
would get if you were to execute that
search it allows you to build complex
searches and it's a powerful tool for
advanced users the search history which
appears under the advanced search at the
bottom half of that screen allows you to
view and download your search history
you can compare the results of various
searches it's sort of a one-stop where
you can see a list of all the searches
you've done you can combine previous
searches view search details and
download your search history so here you
can see that I've run three searches and
then the fourth search was that
combination of the previous searches and
then I can take that search number four
and add it to a subheading and really
have a good way of tracking what I've
done and and what my results have been
from each of these searches now the
search details you'll find here on the
advanced search page and if you click on
that carrot near any one of the searches
you'll see that that expands into your
search details that you're used to
seeing and this will have the search
translation for you you can see that
these are the details of my fifth search
which was the most complicated and it
did you know it keeps everything that
I've sort of rolled up into this search
is presented here for you
you can create search alerts this is
very similar to the functionality that
we have now you can run a search and
then choose to create an alert you get
to name your search you can receive
email updates
specify the frequency specify the format
of your email and how many items you'd
like to see in the email message I'm
going to talk for a minute about the
fact that
the new pubmed Labs is a truly
responsive site this means that the
features you see on the desktop will be
also available on your mobile device
now this development things have to be
optimized for a mobile device you want
to make sure that when you build your
responsive design and when you think
about how it's going to act on a mobile
device you don't want it to override any
native phone features that are really
handy or make it more cumbersome than it
needs to be so there's a lot of design
that's gone into this responsive piece
because there's a lot of information on
some of these pubmed screens and so how
to present that information on a mobile
design is quite a challenge so I just
have listed here a few of the features
that are available on mobile right now
you can log into your my NCBI account if
Advanced Search is actually available we
have filters and the timeline you can
change your sort order that site button
is there share is there you'll see
publisher and PubMed Central icons and
number for the first time we have those
linked out library icons so that if
you're affiliated with an institution
you can have that that icon on every
citation and take advantage of the
subscriptions through your institution
features that are still to come would be
the increased integration with my NCBI
they were actually four there were more
items in this little section until
yesterday when the favorite button
appeared and the custom filters appeared
now really the main push would be that
sent to my bibliography so that you can
send citations directly to your my NCBI
bibliography one of the questions that
we hear a lot is will we have a single
citation matcher for those of you who
use single citation matcher we still
prefer that you try our title sensor and
our know an item sensor in PubMed we
think a lot of people are finding that
that they can have a lot of success if
you can grab the first six or seven
words of the title of an article and put
it in the search box you're you're
likely to get that hit in the PubMed
database however these tools the search
from the mesh database where you're able
to actually go into mesh and build
search and have it run in PubMed same
with the NLM catalog the clinical
queries tool that single citation
matcher if you have a little bit of the
citation information and you prefer to
use the single citation matcher form and
the batch citation matcher these will
all be integrated with PubMed labs when
it becomes default PubMed so what will
happen is whatever whatever day it is
that you go to PubMed and you're
presented with this new PubMed interface
that's the same day that when you search
for mesh your search will be run and
your results will be returned in PubMed
labs so people are looking for these
things they'll be linked off of the new
PubMed homepage and that allows me to
segue into the next bullet which is the
updated PubMed homepage that we're
working on when this is rolled out or
sometime maybe even prior to the rollout
next year there'll be an updated PubMed
homepage and I think seeing that
homepage seeing that the tools that
you're used to seeing on that homepage I
think will will make people happy and
also we're working on a new PubMed API
as I said although you see really what
looks like a refreshed interface this
has been a rebuild from the ground up
it's in a new environment and we need to
build a new API to support it regarding
the communication in planning in
September the new PubMed will be
formally announced by NLM and that means
that PubMed labs will have more words on
it to say this is going to become the
new PubMed production PubMed I
anticipate we'll have a banner that says
this will be replaced by the new PubMed
and we'll encourage people to start
moving over to the new PubMed trying it
out and giving us more feedback and then
in January of 2020 we anticipate that
the new PubMed will be the default after
it becomes the default both current and
new PubMed will run in parallel for
several months so there is not going to
be a day when you are presented with a
new PubMed and you can't get back to the
old PubMed both systems will be there
for several months and then at some
point with war
current production PubMed will be sunset
if you'd like to keep up with what's
happening with this project you can
watch for labs for updates on PubMed
labs in the NLM technical bulletin the
NCBI insights blog and on the PubMed
that labs home page if you scroll down
we actually have a released features
list you can scroll down on the homepage
and see what's what's happened on a
given week month day the national
network of libraries of medicine is
offering a class in September right now
we've scheduled four sessions they have
four sessions scheduled that you'll see
if you follow this link if those
sessions fill will add more or will
increase the attendance there somehow
will accommodate everyone who is an
advanced user of PubMed and is concerned
about things like changes in syntax I
know one thing we've done that that is
integrate more British to English
mappings Morse anonyme more stemming for
example the more consistent mapping of
single singular to plural and that kind
of thing and so those are really the
details that we we'd go into in a
session like that a little bit later on
so that's what I had scheduled for today
I can hear that Jessica's been typing
the whole time I was talking so I think
we've had questions and I can see if
there's anything more that I can answer
for you in the next few minutes the
question was will the name labs be
dropped yes it absolutely will this will
just be PubMed it won't even be new
PubMed it'll it'll just be PubMed so
there have been some questions about
integration of other systems with PubMed
so first I'll talk about the mesh and
NLM catalog again where you can run a
search in those databases and it goes to
PubMed and you see your results it will
just be redirected to the new PubMed
like the rest of the world is so that
should be pretty seamless you'll be
using the the tool that you're used to
whether it's single citation matcher or
a mesh database and then when you hit
search you will go to
new PubMed where you'll see your results
there was another part of the question
oh the my NCBI I've had a lot of people
ask me if they're gonna lose their saved
searches again no that is just
redirecting to the new PubMed your my
NCBI is not going anywhere it's not
being modified it's not being moved it's
just going to be integrated with the new
database yeah so one thing I didn't
mention regarding labs which I really
was remiss in doing if you saw during
the slides and I'll go back to one real
quickly on the bottom of every page in
labs there's a feedback button and it
actually floats with you so if you
scroll down that feedback button will
stay there where you can see it I don't
know if you see it now in the bottom
corner of my screen there when you click
on feedback to send us your questions
about labs those actually go to the
people in this room so it's Kathy
candies and Jessica chan and myself
we'll get those questions and we're
answering those regarding the linkout
transition the same thing is if you
write to the help desk with a link out
question you'll get response directly
from that team we are transitioning from
the link out where we've kept library's
holdings to the outside tool only that
transition is underway we we've
transitioned hundreds of libraries at
this point have moved over to having
their link resolver and using an outside
tool service and we're still planning to
transition at the end of the calendar
year where the link out local Holdings
will not be available any more so at
that point we encourage everyone to have
switched over to an outside tool link
resolver so all right I'm going to try
this but no promises yeah if you're in
labs oh I guess I should do yeah I can't
cheat and just use the canned if
find a mesh indexed record and I'm
looking at it and I scroll down this is
kind of nice because I wanted to show
you the similar articles you can see the
publication types mesh terms if you had
noticed if you if you've been a long
term user of the labs you would notice
that these mesh terms used to appear
almost like a pill shape it was that
pill button and now we've actually
updated that so if you click on this
carrot you have the same actions that
were available in production PubMed you
can search for that term in PubMed you
can search for the term in mesh or you
can add it to your search so that
functionality has been improved just
this week I think this went live as well
when you we run my search again where I
if you are saving to a file and you
choose that I ris format that's
available that's very similar to the
MEDLINE format that you see in pubmed
today except it's an industry standard
so it actually improves the integration
with those citation manager programs
because we're using an industry standard
for that sort of format where you have
the field tag and then the data the
person who's responsible for that is not
in the room and I don't want to speak
for him a couple of days next week it's
already Wednesday so maybe early next
week the recording will be available and
I believe if you're registered for the
webinar you get that recording link sent
to you so there is a title sensor in
PubMed citation matcher in PubMed so if
I were to grab I've had people say well
I use citation single citation matcher
because I need to find a bunch you know
60 citations and I put the title in
single citation matcher oh so I was
gonna start with just a title so if I
put a title in there you can see here
that it write the top of my results 1-1
article found by citation matching
and then the other thing you can also do
is and that title matcher works pretty
well if you have most of the title more
than six or seven words the other thing
you can do is you know sort of this
Smith o Smith sorry
so I've done author name I've got a
journal I've got a year and so it's
pretty smart about figuring out with
that citation matcher that I'm looking
for articles by the author Smith in
science in the year 2000 so it's 11:30
that went by quickly thank you all for
coming there's an encore presentation of
this if you have colleagues who missed
it and don't want to listen to her
recording we're gonna do this again on
August 28th because the registration was
full for this one so if you want to let
people know about that and I appreciate
everyone being here today
if you have any feedback for us go ahead
and use that feedback link and look for
the recording to this webinar next week